[Musique]
m
alors dis salut bienvenue à tous dans un
nouveau format sur la chaîne qui est
donc un format blog très classique qui
va me permettre de choses de vous
partager et d'un pas mal de vidéos que
j'ai dans mes proches et que je
n'intègre jamais aimé mes vidéos
caciques les vidéos que j'écris parce
que ben ça rende pas pile dans la case
et une deuxième truc c'est de pouvoir
partager avec vous pas ma manière et ma
manière de travailler
comment j'écris comment je me documente
comment choisir les sujets de vidéos etc
etc vous montre aussi bas le matériel
que j'utilise le montage est d'ailleurs
balaj envie de commencer par directement
le montage donc là je suis dans le
montage de la vidéo vous avez vu ce que
je vais vous l'aurez déjà vu cette vidéo
moment du blog ne pas vous spoiler c'est
celle de pompéi qui le montage n'avance
pas du tout j'ai pris un retard dingue
c'est à dire que cette vidéo m'a demandé
un temps fou en dérochage donc je suis
parti à la toussaint en italie j'ai
visité pompéi herculanum
rome je n'ai pas rom et donc je vous
dise pas de bêtise j'ai 240 éléments
alors fait un peu plus de 350 roche pour
150 vidéos
il a fallu des rochers ça m'a pris un
temps fou et le plus horrible dans tout
ça c'est que beaucoup de roche ne sont
même pas exploitables
c'est pas vraiment faim si évidemment
c'est de ma faute mais c'était pas prévu
que je foire beaucoup de plantes pas
trop dans mon style mais en fait je suis
allé sur ton pays sur le site avec mon
gh2 et mon trépied tout simplement
pouvoir faire des plans fixés et propre
est en fait vous n'avez pas le droit
d'amener des trépieds sur les sites les
sites historiques
il ya pas mal de moments dans la journée
où j'ai filmé bas où j'ai dû le faire
sans trépied donc la plupart du temps
géruzez en utilisant les colonnes
antiques mai
un ado troubat ça tremble en fait et
c'est pas c'est pas possible
quand j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de rush
comme ça donc c'est vraiment pour les
vidéos en extérieur ce que je fais c'est
que dans mon logiciel de montage
donc c'est première procès c'est 2015
je vous l'avais déjà dit je note avec ça
ça me va très bien je fais d'abord un
premier tri en fait je prends tout ce
qui est exploitable
même les plans qui me semble
complètement inutiles et où il ya une
bonne femme qui passe devant qui regarde
la caméra et ensuite tu vas faire un
second prix ou là je sais par ma
séquence était telle qu'à tous les plans
que j'aime pas je les mets en bout de
séquences filmées sur un côté mais je
sais que si jamais il manque un plan il
manque toujours un plan même si vous
avez je sais pas combien de centaines de
vidéos
il vous manquera toujours le petit plan
qui vous embête et l'autre et bah c'est
mon second tri et là je j'utilise des
coups là je trie en fait mais rush par
par style par exemple à propos pays
j'ai fait voilà en violet j'ai tout les
fresques un les fresques et mosaïques et
d'intérieur de ville à une autre couleur
qui est pour l' architecture donc le
théâtre l'amphithéâtre on a une autre
c'est pour le vésuve
pendant mon séjour à ton pays je suis
monté tout en haut du vésuve
tu peux faire le tour de la moitié du 2
la caldeira fin pouvez voir le cratère
c'est très chouette si vous avez alors
ça coûte un bras et demi pour aller
là-haut ça coûte 20 euros aller retour
en bus way
au départ on a voulu le faire à pied
naples est montée à pied et en fait tout
ça sert à rien parce qu'il n'ya pas de
sentier ya pas de chair c'est la route
qui a emprunté toutes les minutes par
des gros bus donc les bus vous frôlent
ça ça c'est pour mieux payer 20 bal est
allée directement aux le truc cool vous
avez quand même les deux derniers 200
mètres à monter ce qui est rien 1
mais quand même déjà cool marché dans
les cendres dans l'éponte vous avez la
vue sur toute la baie et vous voyez les
styles voyez qu a pris par temps clair
c'est c'est vraiment chouette
je vais finir de poser toutes mes images
au bon endroit
j'aimerais bien faire ça aujourd'hui et
demain
attaquer les recherches de musique pour
la musique
la plupart du temps je vais sur
soundcloud donc pour saint clar de donc
dans la barre de recherche en fait je
tape le style de musique que je
recherche c'est pas moi par exemple
guitare vous avez toute cette recherche
mais c'est le premier truc qui me vient
je mets instrumental parce que je veux
pas de mouvement et ensuite le truc cool
à faire c'est dans c'est d'aller dans
titre de cliquer sur à écouter et là
vous avez le choix a modifié à des fins
commerciales a utilisé à des fins
commerciales a partagé avec août et moi
je mets à
un des deux est donc là je sais que ce
sont des gens qui ont mis leur musique
en
creative commons voilà la plupart du
temps je leur écris gentil vraiment j'ai
utilisé la musique je redis bah voilà
votre musique j'ai utilisé dans dans ma
vidéo je vous mets le lien c'est je
trouve ça plutôt correct je sais pas
trop ce que je mette sur 7
j'aurais bien aimé mettre pink floyd
mais c'est pas possible
si la bbc un mec qui s'amusait à
apprendre de pink floyd
ah ouais
[Musique]
c'est pas mal an
où
on
[Musique]
là je reviens de la poste j'ai enfin
c'est un truc que je devais faire depuis
le mois de septembre c'est à dire
envoyer des colis tipi j'envoie des
quelques contreparties qui me prenne pas
trop de temps à faire sauf justement
celle ci qui était une personne matip et
un montant assez fou de 101 euros et et
comme c'est inscrit sur ma page j'avais
mis ça pour rigoler tu as dit quiconque
me fera un don de 100 euros recevra un
étui pénien en cachemire tricoté par mes
soins et ben voilà il a bien fallu le
tricoter cette équipe et je vous mets
une petite photo du résultat sur moi
alors j'ai fait ça dans les règles de
l'art en cachemire est tous avec les
sangles en cachemire aussi comme ça il
peut se porter sur le coup et attaché à
la taille et je suis pas peu fier du
résultat
voilà et donc c'est enfin parti donc
l'année le lundi 24 janvier et ce
week-end j'ai donc posté la vidéo sur
ton pays ça va un moment donc qu'elle
était en cours de montage et je suis
contente parce que dans les commentaires
vous allez vachement bas donne et
d'anecdotes beaucoup d'entre vous ils
sont allés à ces jeunes d'ailleurs et
c'était chouette d'avoir vos retours sur
cette vidéo est donc là j'avais envie de
partager avec vous une
là une fin alternative à cette vidéo
alors c'est trois fois rien peut même
pas appeler ça une fin alternative mais
au départ la fin ne se terminer par le
plomb sauf vésuve il ya un dernier plan
que j'ai décidé de supprimer
juste avant la publication donc je vous
le montre et puis je vous explique après
pourquoi j'ai fait ça
mais comme vous avez dû le remarquer on
comprend pas grand chose et c'est pour
ça que je les enlever alors que le plan
lui-même me plaît beaucoup c'est donc
roger waters un des membres du groupe de
pink floyd qui dansent un extrait du
film du live qui est donc en interview
avec un journaliste
et ce journaliste lui demande ce qu'il a
pensé de ce film et je trouvais ça
marrant à la fin de la vidéo de 2 m 7
cette question est rangé water si les on
peut dire qu'il est mal polis ils
envoient balader le journaliste en
disant mais tu m'as déjà posé cette
question vas-y enchaîne ça m'intéresse
dans et mais c'est pas une capture écran
les les extraits du live de pompéi show
filmé en fait ce sont des choses que
j'ai filmé à pompéi il y avait une
exposition le joues rosissent j'y suis
allée pardon au coup de bol sur le live
à pompéi
c'était génial on pouvait déambuler dans
l'amphithéâtre en écoutant pink floyd et
en voyant da toutes les images que qui
sont dans la vidéo j'aurais pu mettre un
extrait du film et j'avais un peu pour
être tout à fait franc j'ai un peu peur
du strike donc bon je vais enlever au
moins je peux vous la montrer dans le
blog et c'est ça qui compte
autre chose là que s'est passé ce
week-end c'est que j'ai commencé à
écrire une conférence une conférence que
je vais donner avec pierre kerner du
blog stein stein funky things si vous ne
connaissez pas ce blog je vous invite
vraiment aller faire un tour ça parle de
biologie mais aussi d'archéologie et
c'est pour ça qu'on comment travailler
ensemble et donc on donne une conférence
au playa sur festival à nice qui se
déroule le
c'est le 11 février prochain et on va
donc faire une conférence sur accrochez
vous bien les coprolithe ce sont les
crottes fossilisés des humains et des
animaux du passé qu'on étudie donc en
biologie et en archéologie parce que ça
nous donne plein d'informations sur le
régime des animaux et des hommes à une
époque précise sur les espèces végétales
la faune et la flore qui sont présentes
également à cette époque on donne pleins
pleins d'infos et là je pense partir sur
plusieurs bouquins en fait ce sont des
vrais bouquin scientifique voyez c'est
écrit en anglais
il n'y a pas d'image et il ya plusieurs
colonnes partage ça c'est pas très funky
comme publication et moi mon but c'est
de rendre sa femme qui est intelligible
donc voilà au départ je voulais partir
sur un livre de vulgarisation que je
vous conseille d'ailleurs si vous voulez
un ouvrage en préhistoire très très bien
le fait c'est qu'un abel aussi par jean
guilaine qu'un super livre mais qui
m'apporte un peu mal son titre
parce que moi j'ai été tassé par la
partie haute si otis un homme congelés
une sorte de momies des glaces on a
retrouvé
je sais plus quand on est tanné 90 et
dont on a fouillé les intestins et donc
on a pu fouiller
cc oui d'intérieur et d'intestins pour
connaître la composition dernière au
pain donc je voulais le mentionner dans
la conférence je vais le faire mais ce
livre là bas ils parlent pas vraiment de
dothy en lui-même c'est plus une
réflexion générale sur la préhistoire
en tout cas si vous cherchez un bon
bouquin sur ses tables à sur le
néolithique sur la préhistoire et même
bas ça reprend ça fait crips possible de
la bible vraiment vraiment bien c'est
très accessible et c'est pas très bon
d'aller au boulot
[Musique]
tj ce n'est quand même pas